okay did you need my help in the kitchen
[Laughter]
how about you
'd once instead of waiting for your wife
who's
who's kind of woman State the hell away
from them oh one second what does she
say one second where's the mic one
second one sec say that again
I have come together again with one
woman charity who I trust Hamden Allah
who had 100 donation policy we are now
raising funds to build houses for those
who have been homeless due to natural
disasters in Afghanistan Syria and
Pakistan please donate whatever you can
may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
and sisters and dear friends this is a
clear-cut refutation video I'm not
joking a four dirty pink I think that's
what he Deshawn said that it looks like
a dirty pink color for a reason because
I've been speaking to the feminist so I
thought you know ping maybe they can
resonate to that here is a video that I
shared yesterday giving the men a
reminder about how they should be
patient with their woman folk when
they're cooking at home only a feminist
can do the twist that they did on this
video Let's watch for ourselves
inshallah
so my wife was late cooking today I'm
hungry I'm starving I've been fasting
I've been working how could you do that
relax yourself Ralph our wives can delay
food for whatever reason it may be these
things happen my wife got to be quiet
with other stuff today he's playing on
the outside sharing appointments so she
the food was late meaning right now I'm
gonna break my fast weather date and I
thought to myself instead of staying at
home no problem these things happen I'll
be going inshallah I'll be going
inshallah to the gym right now to do a
drug when I'm back the food should be
ready Brothers you need to understand
sometimes there are situations there's
things that happen in the house she gets
busy with a b c d whatever maybe be
understanding you will never see the
prophet salallahu ever make a fuss about
fruit ever this is the Sunnah we follow
now the red pill not feminism none of
that we follow the Sunnah inshallah just
a little reminder in Ramadan for the
brothers be patient be patient brother
and sisters inshallah so guys as you saw
for yourself not in a Million
my wife with
so deluded so perverted could take such
a video where I am reminding and giving
this year to men to be patient when
things don't arrive on time for many
good reasons my wife specifically had an
appointment she came early actually she
came home around half five so there was
a good two hours 10 minutes to cook she
had plenty of time but still it's not
it's not that deep you know things
happen it was late no problem look at
the comment section before we go to the
comment section actually you know what
let's go to the comment section first
then we're gonna go to the video with me
and my wife and how we react to these
toxic radical tapped in the head
feminists this is what they are if you
ever wonder why Brothers like Matty who
have some extreme views quite a lot of
extreme views exist and why the red pill
movement exists and why our young men
are going and following them just read
these comment sections I'm about to read
you and then we're going to watch the
video with me and my wife and how they
managed to change this whole thing into
something it's not here are the comment
section I'm gonna read it here we go so
basically this is from one of the
sisters LOL how about you do the cooking
for once instead of waiting for your
wife who's obviously busy to cook oh
wait that makes me a feminist right my
bad did did you make this video and
thought doing something special now and
doing something to be praised for having
patience when the food is delayed
shouldn't even be something to discuss
it's the bare minimum but I forgot that
men are always praise for doing the bare
minimum or like why don't you take her
out to eat if there wasn't enough time
to cook she was probably also fasting
and is hungry and would be happy about
it but no you are to praise cause you
didn't complain about the delayed food
to your wife respect you for your
patience Ali yes and this is the same
woman towards the end of the comment
tells me about all you men who rape and
kill and this do this and this the woman
yeah these are the issues that we're
facing now let's read again and only
that not just radical feminists we've
got people from the red pill nah I
wouldn't tolerate it she has one job to
do and stay home and cook not too much
to ask now we have the right medical
feminists and the radical red pills and
another one if you didn't have a wife
and your mom is no longer in the world
are you going to starve yourself because
you're you're waiting on someone for
being late on the preparation I don't
think so maybe try to help so your poor
belly doesn't stop you can break your
fast by Try by drinking wood while
driving water it says while drinking
water and date as recommended in the
Sunnah if you're complaining then maybe
you should help now guys if you see the
comment section these radical feminists
now bear in mind I am advising men to be
patient which men am I talking about do
you guys think that I sit at home and
play Playstation an Xbox Not For a
Moment in that comment section did any
of these females these toxic radical
feminist hijabis said hold on a second
maybe Ali came back from work providing
for his family maybe Ali was tired and
exhausted well if it may be and by the
way these are all speculations and
assumptions that my wife needed help and
that I said no my wife was fasting or
she was Ill or something happened to her
what a perverted mind you must have now
before we conclude this video here is a
slap in the face from my wife to these
radical feminists and then we're going
to conclude on some simple statements in
Charlotte sisters so guys I'm here
having apple crumble my wife made it
because I told her to otherwise you'll
be Peak is that correct yeah that's
right anyways if it's a joke anyways I'm
joking guys all right now guys go back
to topic remember he was out today you
had you had to go somewhere yeah and
what did you want to do for us today
okay and by the way you usually you you
cook anyways yeah okay did I say to you
you have to cook nice why did you cook
why did you want to cook okay you want
to cook yeah okay so you went and you
went to a specific dish right which
takes about two hours to cook in the two
three hours okay remember when it was
late and I said to you don't worry you
can make something simple yeah okay by
the way I'm happy you need to do this is
your life on the Fret not are you sure
about that yeah you sure about that
sorry
um
okay sister food was taking too long to
cook okay I decided to go to the gym
right yeah okay did you need my help in
the kitchen
[Laughter]
honestly I'll be honest be honest
no did you honestly no okay when I went
to the gym you did not say like can you
come and help me okay I thought I would
go by the time my mom comes and my dad
comes I'll be back right correct okay
now people are making assumption number
one and you're not fasting right yeah
okay I'm not forcing you you're not
fasting yeah yeah exactly so guys you
saw that for yourself me and my wife
look we have a sense of humor okay so
it's clear how my relationship is with
my wife I don't want to get into too
much details and talk about you know
praising myself she knows my wife knows
what kind of a man I am she knows what
kind of a father I am and she knows what
kind of a person I am you know I'm
alhamdulillah and I don't want to get
into too much detail because I don't
want to get a second wife proposals
thank you very much now I'll be very
honest on blunt yeah see me as someone
bad I'm happy me and my wife happy you
can seem as bad I beat my wife up that's
fine and good the point I'm seeing is
the following guys look how they Twisted
it now I'm eating apple crumble in that
video after my wife cooked she went and
did apple crumble yeah and I actually
looked and I said you know what you're
probably tired but it's fine she said no
I want to make up a crumble for us I
said well you go Go I mean come on slay
the day babe you know like these
feminists will say you go babe you know
alhamdulillah she went and made
hamdullah a apple crumble and we was
eating this laughing at and none of
these radical toxic feminists and red
pill were under that video that I made
guys this is the problem of our ummah
this is the problem the reason I'm doing
this video is not to be Petty this shows
you that the assumptions and
speculations they made about me and my
wife when my wife handler was cooking
she's the one who chose to cook that
specific dish that day which was a roast
that takes two to three hours I even
called them myself and by the way when
she she had to go out on the way back
she was getting some shopping I was
looking after my our daughter our kids I
was looking after our children
alhamdulillah I'm not mentioning this to
prove a point I mentioned this because
all these female toxic radical hijabis
who destroy family units they did not
for once say hold on a second maybe Ali
was doing this and that I was working at
home that day yeah working at home and
managing two kids Handler and changing
their nappies yes I am proud to say that
my own children I change their nappies
when my wife was out she had an
appointment to go she took my car
Abdullah she's in short on I pay for the
bills and electric gas council tax
shopping you name it alhamdulillah okay
the point is this though none of those
women for a second said maybe Ali is
working no no no no no you know what
this shows this shows they don't give a
single damn about what men do and these
kind of women do not marry them guys I'm
telling you these kind of women State
the hell away from them I thank Allah
day and night and the brothers that we
have traditional women my wife loves
cooking she doesn't like me coming near
the kitchen if she needs help which she
did by the way I can remember that day I
poured the lemon juice she told me her
hands were occupied she said can you get
the lemon I got the lemon and I just I
said I'm squeezing and she said stop
that's the only thing I did that day I
squeezed a lemon like a real man onto
that roast that was the only thing I did
so guys and sister specifically anytime
you see me being harsh with this stuff
just know I'm doing it for your own
betterment because if you carry on with
this nonsense attitude with that last
sister a messaging about oh but what are
you gonna do if your mom and your wife
is not there yeah how about me coming
and saying you know what imagine for a
second I go to my wife and say you know
imagine that I'm not here who's going to
pay for the rent electric gas bill
insurance
who's going to pay for this what a
stupid dumb thing an analogy to give
they are expecting a man who works and
provides to come home and cook you guys
are tapped in the head well why you guys
are mad you guys are crazy and I'll give
you something to be more crazy about how
about that the prophet salallahu said if
I was to ask anyone to prostrate to
anyone it will be the wife to the man
burn in your age sister yep feminist
sister pull your hair out and like I
always say go to Turkey get hair
transplant it's fine you toxic
individuals you showed and prove to me
once again that a simple Nasir that I
gave to men how you've twisted that
around alhamdulillah you didn't need to
reply for me do not have an issue with
people who are women who choose to be
traditional women who serve their
husbands may Allah bless and preserve
them and when the prophet salallahu said
too if he asked for anyone to bow down
to anyone prostrate will be the wife to
the husband it's because of a good man
anytime we say this like the sister said
you men rape and kill this perception of
this evil man that you have your head
keep it for yourself yeah don't paint us
with the same brush keep it to yourself
and that's all I want to say did I miss
anything shut your mouth and in a
nutshell I am starting to see more of
this trend any time anytime I guess
who's calling my wife let me answer you
know what my name is
yeah sorry I'm just doing another
reputation video of um you know
yesterday we reflected those feminists
together yeah I'm just finishing the
obviously anything you would like to add
to them I'm doing it for YouTube no
she's just laughing she's saying there's
nothing else to be said yeah yeah I'm
live you're also alive inshallah is
there anything you want to give them
something this year maybe it should be a
traditional woman oh one second what did
she say one second where's the mic one
second one sec say that again I said to
respect your husband
I think I think we can end on that uh uh
sisters
and just a disclaimer before we finish
guys sorry there
I'm fasting now if I call my wife to do
that if I called her now and told her to
say that or even call me yeah there you
go you're finished